thank you to manscaped and Shopify for
sponsoring the channel this week more on
them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation
John and Coy are back in the saddle woo
for First Blood we've never seen it I
have recently learned that the sequel is
called First Blood Part Two I found that
hilarious if you also found hilarious
and also want us to potentially watch
First Blood Part Two please like Please
Subscribe if you're not ready please
comment below saying hey watch First
Blood Part Two a kind of funny named
title with a lot of redundancies and
numbering and I'd like to thank the fine
folks at prepper for helping cut down
these highlights making it sing making
it have some Bazzaz just giving it that
little extra oomph and also if you want
to watch this in its entirety front to
back beginning to end the entirety all
of the blood both first second and third
become a patron you see all the blood
spilled any bit of it I assume there's
more than one I hope so I mean
grab your boxed set copy and you know
you can let us know and then you can
sync up and we can all enjoy I mean this
is a 1982 filming case I miss the first
Blood because of filming camera quality
know that I made a joke going oh it's
the first blood in advance right that's
when the best jokes happen when you
think of them in advance and they're off
the cuff pre recorded that's the intro
you want all right let's get into
[Music]
it oh
a mournful pensive intro not a lot of
trumpets and openings anymore
yeah tamber of the fallen
soldier look at this beautiful film
grain damn it's a beautiful establishing
shot Rambo rolling into town wonder who
directed this the credits will not tell
us they won't tell us it's your job to
figure it out all right maybe infer
David Caruso hey oh I'm excited to see
what uh what version of himself he
brings to
this it's just comic relief also shouts
out to ALF Humphrey's my uh cat eating
long lost
[Music]
ancestor oh it's beautiful oh welcome to
the
heartland
and those feathery locks 80s were a
different time for hair I know you could
have a totally different hair do and be
you know a man like a macho man you
could get feathered and be a macho man
it's almost like ferah faades yeah but
still
manly oh that's right it's an adaptation
just imagine Stallone reading it like oh
this pretty good you know no
Adrian Ted
KF my favorite director don't don't K
can you tell me this where Delmar Barry
lives he ain't here is he dead no no oh
he's a friend of mine as a matter of
fact he wrote this address down you can
see that's delm Mo's writing that's his
writing John Rambo we served on the same
team together in N I don't know if you
ever talked about me all the time he
always loved talking about the old days
in
N that's uh Dan for in Westmore Bronson
Ortega and there's delmare right in the
back had to put him in the back cuz he's
so big if he didn't he he'd take up the
whole picture look how big he is dma's
gone yeah what time will he be back he
died no died last summer cancer oh
brought it back from there good old
agent orange cut him down to nothing I
could lift him off the Sheep oh jeez
poor thing very
[Music]
sorry sorry
feel I mean we are but it feels like a
totally different era of Cinema
especially with what you associate a
Rambo movie with right you would thought
Rambo would be like this so far I mean
this could this could pop off but like
[Music]
yeah it's like a good tone Setter that
scene yeah it's really just heavy and
the weight of
war and two the vistas man the vistas
well yeah and you show up at this like
idilic Lakehouse and now you're in like
the shadow of a mountain and like things
are already looking dreier yeah walking
through the yeah this guy was everywhere
in the
80s it's going to be a good day on the
be oh the belly
tap hope motel that beautiful town man
yeah my God I do love a good mountain
town yeah I'm a sucker for a small
mountain town good
[Music]
vacation he's just like Jack Reacher he
just always out on the highway you know
wearing that flag on that jacket looking
the way you do you're asking for trouble
around here friend really headed north
or south north now jump in I'll take you
to the clink I'll get you out of my town
yeah where you headed Portland Portland
is South you said you were heading north
you got some place I can eat around here
there's a diner about 30 Mi up the
highway
what that's the only hundreds of places
is there any law against me getting
something here yeah me why are you
pushing me what did you say oh so why
are you pushing me I haven't done
anything to you first of all you don't
ask the questions around here I do this
is an interrogation we don't want guys
like you in this town Drifters first
thing you know we got a whole bunch of
guys like you in this town that's why
there dudes out here running drills
everywhere 5% body fat handsome Italian
models in fact you might say it's boring
but that's the way we like it and I get
paid to keep it that way boring so did I
I thought guy hates men with feathered
hair just real profiling about it that's
the true nature is Prejudice I can't do
that why should
you Portland Straight
Ahead literally the Town Line of Hope
freaking
hope
have a nice day
huh thanks man appreciate you I do
respect an anti-cop movie in 1982 in the
height of like copaganda sure like
that's at least a different opening yeah
different commentary how many cops has
Stallone played in the 80s and here he
is getting hassled by a
[Music]
[Laughter]
cop hell you think you're
going hey I'm talking to you
goddamn come on man see some
ID all right you're under arrest now you
put your hands in the car and you spread
them Spread spread my hands now you're
going to put your hands on that car how
you do it you decide right now take them
out Rambo yeah pick up the car and smash
[Music]
yeah oh we yeah here
huh
ooh ooh Why would you be carrying a
knife like this hunting a Michael M what
do you hunt with a knife anything you
hunt I guess guns are more effici for
some stuff but carving them up yeah good
morning Arthur morning
will what you got want you to book this
gentleman for vagrancy resisting arrest
freaking pig ornament police station
jeez
damn hey
Mitch Mitch yo esort this young man
downstairs oh yes sir yeah I got this
covered that's
it yes get him
Archie you know it looks like it's going
to take o Leroy about 10 years to make
this Hall Leroy
Jenkins my grandpa's name is Leroy you
don't hear it enough great name Leroy
yeah you could be Lee or Roy or Leroy
which is like the three names three
Roy that's what I name my kid three
Roy your
name your
name oh oh [__]
whoa wait a
second Jesus you got three seconds
before I break your face in he means it
I do I don't know man you think you can
get one over on this
guy
W oh that's little David Caruso holy
[__] oh I did not put that together at
all this whole time yeah he's right in
front of us didn't recognize him with
sunglasses you know and his head's all
his neck is all straight Rambo JN J I
promise you're going to talk to me
Soldier I'm starting to dislike you
lot are we going to beat up a lot of
cops I think he's going to Michael like
he's going to Assault on Precinct 13
this place yes it won't work that way
it'll only smear and I'll run across
look you son of a [__] if you don't put
your goddamn hand down there I'm going
to break it
off down what the hell is going on down
here oh nothing I can't
handle clearly he won't let us print him
well leave the ink
on at 10:00 tomorrow morning you're
going up in front of that judge and you
think we're tough that judge is going to
be beat the [__] out of you clean him up
makeover I want you to go over and get
that hose ready all right that dude's
voice is crazy yeah right o the
scars oh Christ who Damn we should
report this to teasel G look at that he
got the old school buff body yeah it's
like functional strength and like it's
it makes your ribs really prominent why
his body type so crazy so wide and small
yeah he needs to beat up so many cops my
god oh no John ram
butt how you like Jesus Christ yeah
those fire hoses that would hurt so much
yeah H up my coffee break oh that's
so oh Jesus got the mustache in the past
see there I knew he I'm just going to
shave you part take it easy yeah how
about to shave let's get some Sweeney
Todd in here
oh flashbacks are
intense
Jesus
ah good yeah
[Music]
wowe you son of a [__] come on what did
you expect yeah seriously you got a man
you put him as a caged animal and he's
trained
God these guys are the worst yeah
they've earned all
[Music]
this hell
is that a great like jump cut so you
think he's over here that was fantastic
I like that they G it 15 minutes of just
cops being [__] to earn this yeah
yeah it really gets you on Rambo's
side
oh
Jesus that old school glass oh it's
beautiful yeah that thin old school
movie glass
yeah oh there's a deli right there I was
looking for this
Jesus oh damn I like the double check on
the
[Music]
guy this is a secret Christmas movie too
see the lights y Christmas Christmas
Cannon Ram add it to the Christmas list
yep whoa was that him y it did not sound
like him was that weird ADR there's a
coffee shop there's The Godfather Pizza
steak Easter eggs Coca-Cola there's so
much food here very upset at these lies
30 miles Diner no
way wa convenient ramp oh
dang oh ain't no way that car would have
survived that car did not land that way
that boat would not buckled that one
shot was one car the second shot was we
that was a good stun though cuz usually
in in a lot of old movies you'll see the
first half and the car like clearly
breaks in half and then you cut to the
next shot
it's wowe the action's been amazing so
far yeah get that suspension boy oo
those cars man they used to be built ah
yeah and like a real steady ramp up up
too cuz it starts quiet it gets slightly
more agitated as time goes by and now
like I'm and well earned every bit of it
white knuckling
this pavement water mud My Cousin
Vinnie's just in the next Motel just
like out there trying to get the car out
I was going to say what's he gonna do in
this environment yeah posit traction
you're going to get stuck in the
[Music]
mud and all the while like the scenery
is so gorgeous consistently yeah I
wonder it's Colorado maybe it's what it
looks like it definitely yeah it looks
like the Pacific Northwest if he was
head to Portland like some outside
between Colorado and Portland town I'm
guessing cuz everyone's in the comments
about geography right now they're like
guys why don't you know
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah [__] a practical stunt an upside
down cop car that makes me
happy
[Music]
look at wow whoa another great stunt I
was like was that planned or did they
just run with that all right this is the
story now oh he'll look there what are
you what are you doing John Rambo oh
[__] he's Gathering stuff oh yeah it's
cold in the Pacific Northwest in
December yeah he's going to need to make
a Sasquatch
suit
oh get that KN makes an Immaculate
leather jacket yeah
yes [__] get orille on the radio tell
him to get out here with his damn dogs
right away they're tell him to bring the
Doberman it's going to rain we'll need
dogs that can hunt on sight right oh boy
the K9
unit you know what why don't you just
call the National Guard just in case
it's real ironic homemade Poncho yeah
buddy oh is that a compass this is a
very interesting commentary cuz like I
like we don't have a goodt already of
taking care of our veterans but it's
also like I I forget that like Vietnam
Vets especially were like pretty shunned
coming back yeah they survive all that
and they come back to this yeah like the
the way people are so unsympathetic
toward him
like keep those dogs I don't trust those
bastards keep moving cuz my dog's going
to eat and run at the same
time we should all be so lucky great
opening line for that character yeah
that's what he audition
with my dog oh can I start
again whoa that's a beautiful shot wow
oh my God he looks like a monk right
now's go
bab oh that would
suck
God how beautiful and you know they just
had to perch across that Ridge with a
long ass L
yeah Chapman gge head
off God this is like they're hunting
some kind of like bobcat that's been
eating every feel all the dogs hunting
plus the aerial
yeah in this movie he is the
Predator oh good cut excellent
framing
oh oh my God no what are what that would
suck what great tension in this
movie oh [__] what are you doing we're
just supposed to spot him hold I can't
Jesus man you can't go any
place you don't Li thing right
I swear to God will kill you this guy is
a sociopath absolute madman Mountain cop
oh Shu christe
[Music]
oh oh just kick off the ledge catch onto
the helicopter swing it around I think
he's going to grab that tree
yeah oh
who God he's flipping I'm was it going
to how was he going to catch
it ow
slow as fall I guess yeah do a high fall
into some Thin
branches
ow Jesus oh I miss that like I think
they used to sell these kinds of things
a lot more with just like the dude being
in pain yeah the 80s especially I feel
like we threw our actors at stuff yeah
this is like the early 80s yeah ' 802
cuz this has like still some of that 70s
just like immediacy of just like shit's
just happen
now like you know but also yeah but the
80s like brutal action totally our movie
stars are going to actually get hurt
some
yeah Jesus
Christ oh my God they really did this
with a helicopter this is an insane
stunt unless they have it on an arm I
think some of the shots are on an arm
but a lot of it's
jeez
[Music]
who it's like ah it's so good yes Rambo
V helicopter Rambo wins and it's just
enough that you buy it yeah like if this
was right now that the the helicopter
would have a machine gun y it would have
exploded he would hit the rotor and it
would have exploded yeah yeah and it
would have like chopped the tree in
halfs like oh oh my God ow oh Jesus yeah
smoke it that
guy
no take his coat yeah and his wallet and
his keys I mean it's cold and draw a
mustache on him get warm dude God though
just to have a helicopter weaving back
and forth just with the one rifle is
just like perfect couldn't happen to a
nicer guy oh no no no
sh whoa who God that's brutal he was my
son's Godfather I have harble tast in
Frets what isn't in the handle of this
knife oh oh needle and thread smart D
dude
[Music]
resourceful yeah buddy will looks like
he wants to turn himself
in yeah I didn't do
anything Jesus what what what hit him
what did it looked like he got hit in
the face yeah like did a rock Ricochet
like he got if he got shot in the face
John rainbow though that's true John
rainbow I want that Chopper back here
right now I don't want G's body out here
all night he's already drawn yeah first
Blood
oh
oh snuck it right up on me Coy he's a
green beray Congressional Medal of Honor
guy's a war hero I knew there was
something about that guy I love that
guy I want you to to do what I told you
to do godamn it get that Chopper back
here now out get the chopper to to here
yeah it's trademark somebody else why
don't you let the state police
handlist yes the real badasses stadies
yeah is dead because of that pycho out
there now you listen boy and you listen
to me good I'm going to get that son of
a [__] and I'm going to pin that
Congressional Medal of Honor to his
liver wow that's
specific Jimmy Olsson is not getting a
raise
no he's not going to be working at the
pr much longer that's how he goes and
works at the paper he's like I got to
document this stuff atro White's chill
compared to this life upbringing yeah
come over
here it's going to storm oh it was a
dark and stormy
[Music]
Rambo oh
Jesus whoa whoa whoa he definitely has
The High Ground I was going to ask where
the police got these assault rifles but
then I remembered that we live in
America yeah uh you mean at Walmart yeah
why don't they have more assault rifles
where is the police tank a nice guy with
a gun will solve all of this kill him go
get him go get him go get him
me yeah you should get your other dog
killed I hope he bonds with the dog
sends him back at his owner eats his
owner's leg
off CH you cover it look at his leg what
wasn't he just sending the dog out and
fine is he had a heart attack the second
the dog got nipped the dog was keeping
him alive that's true yeah his life
force is
[Music]
connected good Moody soundtrack too I've
enjoyed the score which I forget who the
composer was now but pretty prolific
composer I got to see what the rest of
the director's work is cuz some of these
lockoff shots and these like slow pans
have been Genius Like That opening
lockoff like pivot and now these it's
really like sweeping and the set I think
is
great oh I
didn't so good so good so good oh no
Archie yeah we don't know that he was
trying to stop them from killing
him [__] oh boy yeah he's he's drawing
you guys out it was also smart to just
wound the one goodish one yeah it's
smart give you the warning cuz the rest
of these guys going to get
worse
Predator let's go let's
[Music]
go he's everywhere and even the score
sounds like an alien like
yeah oh
jeez oh my
god wow he's out of bullets but they're
not jeez man you got something you shot
your boy ow
Predator trap I didn't realize there was
Spikes all over that's what you was
shaving before yeah oh my thighs nut
spiked oh
ow oh it is no nut November yeah he got
it worst of all yep oh God oh God oh
cruo needs to be here to say that guy's
nuts
whoa now open the Ark of the Covenant so
efficient with the murder yeah and I
guess they're not dead all of them
but ah dude he was in frame again I
could have killed
you been telling you the law not here
it's me oh
yeah yeah oh don't push it I'll give you
a war you won't believe let it go home
baby oh oh my God let go can't hold me
back
[Music]
anymore give you a war you won't believe
that was an incredible delivery of some
lines that could not have worked yes
like on paper i' read that be like well
don't know I like Stallone a lot in this
really enjoy so much better than I
expected yeah I thought this was going
to be a Cheesy shoot them up like I I
enjoyed uh you know the dread movie for
what it was but I expected more that
sure sure or like watch something like
Demolition Man yeah this is like a good
movie well and he's like embodying this
character in a in a more Earnest way and
it's got way more to say yeah yeah in
its own ways cuz like obviously the
militia man had plenty to say and so to
dread but this is a more subtle story to
tell yeah way way less like wacky
satirical right it's not like a
commentary in a way of like is that what
that means it's like well clearly yeah
good thing to come out of this are doing
a
town drink Place dry got that Leon S
Kennedy
jacket why don't you go home don't give
me any of your horeshit about
jurisdiction in this one you understand
you like me to step outside just finish
up what you're doing yes I think can I
leave one godamn bit of difference Dave
and you know it oh God people this with
the law and all hell breaks
loose 40 years later so glad things have
gotten better oh they it was so much
better this movie fixed everything I
made him hell you Colonel Samuel
Troutman Colonel Troutman Metal Gear so
many movies in Metal Gear I trained him
I commanded him in Vietnam for 3 years
I'd say that makes him mine yeah buddy
send a full bird colonel down here to
handle this the Army thought I might be
able to help cuz he just whooped your
hole Yeah Jesus Rambo's a civilian now
he's my problem yeah he has none of his
soldierly training or
experiences I didn't come here to rescue
Rambo from you I came here to rescue you
from him oh you're stuck in here with me
S such a good line strictly speaking he
slipped up you're lucky to be breathing
that's just
great is in Vietnam his job was to
dispose of enemy Personnel to kill win
by attrition the Rambo was the best you
idiot halfway in that speech so good
like it it's the escalation not with
violence but with like what he's capable
of and then more violence it's crazy
that they just lifted that character
wholesale and put him in Metal Gear like
that and steak piskin like literally
whoa good cut great cut he was hungry
are you telling me that 200 men against
your boy is a no- win situation for us
you send that many don't forget one
thing what a good supply of body bags
yeah dude think of yourself in a
position to send 200 guys after one guy
maybe you don't want to do that if
you're serious about taking Rambo out
clean follow me move I love that that
closed the like well yeah that's the
obvious thing to do and also the ego on
the guy's hick town thing like like
every dialogue scene is as important as
the action scenes totally totally and
just to watch the earlier is like this
is just a pleasant sleepy town the whole
place upside down like State Police
calling John Rambo come in please if
you're listening Rambo here's your
situation you are surrounded every
possible exit has been blocked God it's
like a total war zone now if I was in
his position I'd try to pick up some
information maybe catch some cross talk
of course he's listen we call that Intel
maybe you can talk him into sparing all
our lives by giving himself up at least
we'll get a radio fix on his position if
you don't mind setting them up for us
that's like bringing the pigeons to the
cat CER calling
Raven oh yeah this one's different Cy
leader to identify Baker te Rambo mnar
Keta Jorgenson Dan for the whole unit
yeah and we knew some of the names from
before in that opening scene that's
smart yeah it's everybody named to the
picture it's a good like you can trust
me Beacon yeah wonder if there's a code
in there too yeah probably are you all
right over Baker team They're All Dead
sir not Delmore Barry Barry's gone too
sir a I tried to get in touch with you
but the guys at Brag never knew where to
find you yeah well I haven't been
spending much time there lately they've
got me down in DC I'm shining a seat
with my ass we'll talk about that when
you come in I can't do that sir yeah
well you did some pushing on your own
John
they drew first blood not me first Blood
great use of title as plot yeah as
actual meaningful dialogue ramble
acknowledge he all finished Colonel come
first light I'm going to put every man I
got up on that Ridge now we'll get him
my way I don't think he'll be there
first light yeah or he'll be just above
yeah come on
Mo and the big military DRS these and
these are the guys marching to their
Doom
Predator what irony too cuz like as a
soldier you must be seeing all sorts of
exotic and beautiful places doing
like they're so good at those shots my
man the yeah the camo shots in this are
terrific but yes the irony of yeah being
so many beautiful places for so many
horrific reasons yeah exactly like
Vietnam looks beautiful but o this way
let's
go ER style graft of First Blood onto
Punisher like Yeah The Kingpin is the
big deep boy like it's just there's so
much oh
[Music]
boy that train tracks right up there oh
he's staying AB mine oh it's a mine okay
we got there no shooting I don't want
him dead I want him
alive if I your man yep just like the
number one most ignored request in this
movie is to stop shooting Ammon what I
want you to go in that mine oh not me
what do you mean not me look I do this
part time I didn't come here to get
killed oh my God Buro guys just reserves
for the paycheck that deal with Rambo
it's your last chance to come out maybe
we should wait Earl this creep is a
killer besides I'm in charge and I say
we blow it up maybe I want to yell that
one just screaming our plan my voice is
one level we need to rocket launcher him
now Jesus
God oh my God into the mine release the
b
rock
yeah give that man a
seagar
b n Flanders got the shot some of these
scenes man some of these bits I feel
like it's a weird pull but Jason lives
took some stuff from some of these seeds
and put it in their paintball sequ
SE it involves a bunch of people
paintballing and Army outfits and I feel
like it's partly inspired by this I mean
Rambo influenced so much I wouldn't be
surprised any of those PS in lines
Soldier of Fortune Soldier of Fortune
Christ damn it what the hell do you
think this is something out of a circus
got to get our emima pick wow W ghoulish
he was shooting at us will come on I
wasn't taking any chances this is great
too because it's kind of skewering like
the
actual solidity of the structural
hierarchy it's your mess Clinton you
clean it up well come on I got to be
back at the drug store tomorrow and you
better get started right
away Jesus man and his lack of value of
human life at all and he's just a guy at
the drug store yeah at the drug store of
all
places I like that while Troutman isn't
like 100% like scot-free of any
culpability like he's still resourceful
and he's still like one of the few kind
of benevolent presences yeah more on his
side like obviously he tried to trick
him into saying they get out of there
but but at least he kind of understands
and yeah he's sort of rooting for
him
oh ah oh that was a great stunt holy
crap how'd they do that the S looks so
real yeah and the variables of how that
could have gone wrong some of these
stuns do feel like that they just went
with whatever kind of film you falling I
know he got like you know his ribs
broken his heart stopped and stuff in
Rocky like I wonder how much like Dolph
lungren stopped his heart in one of the
scenes they were fighting in Rocky and
he had to go to the hospital and like
basically get brought back if he dies he
dies that almost happened yeah wow will
[Music]
teasel oh you going to have to swim
oh have to that'd be so scary to not
know like you know you don't know if
there's an out yeah but your only option
is to put out your Visual and this water
has smaller and smaller and yeah oh it's
going be so cold it's going to be cold
and murky as [__] like you probably
can't see through this water rat oh them
rats Indiana John look at them all oh my
God that's a good sign that there's an
an exit though yes oh they're on his
back oh my God wa they're biting them I
mean they're hungry rats do bite
oh God this is like the Descent just
with mice instead rat I didn't know how
this was going to go and I don't like it
it's great storytelling and I'm
uncomfortable elements
[Music]
man not like extremely claustrophobic
but I I like to think I'm claustrophobic
within reason yeah I like to think I
have survival instincts and but this
would be this would be a bit paranoid
yeah also don't have anything against
rats but that scene got me yeah oh I
have friends with pet rats I have no
problem with but that was a
[Music]
lot come on
Ramy God man where do they build these
or find these caves that'd be filmed in
the volume now yeah yeah right if I was
out of line before I uh I just want to
apologize when at what point I mean what
would you have done with him if he came
in would you wrap your arms around him
give him a big sloppy kiss or would you
have blown his brains up I want to see
that kiss we've all learned
it I couldn't answer that until I met
him face to face well there it is it's
just as well we never got a chance to
find out also the leaders of military
out there casually drinking and he's
still like yeah it's also an interesting
moment of power hierarchy yeah and like
dis the the discomfort for lack of a
better word versus discomfort where it's
like they're sitting over a table like
stressing about this situation where
he's like completely ring it to the max
yeah can you imagine that relief oh God
seeing the sun without a guarantee of
that ever
[Music]
like it's a good thing they don't keep
too good records of where the mind let
out or the different entrances
[Music]
are oh man man whoa it was not far at
all jeez oh my god oh wow they are right
there that was also a very similar shot
to the opening where it has him come
into frame and then it turns yeah so
it's like now poetry it Rhymes
Rhymes it'sit ride
Rambo don't look at me look at the road
that's how accidents happened
yeah
okay Rob get out of the truck I got no
beef with you go on move go home yeah go
home you're welcome no beef that Rambo
guy is on the loose again
[__] it's Rambo he's still
around love a man's asleeping in the
foreground it's such a great like I
missed that in the ' 80s movies like
Lethal Weapon always has stuff in the
frame yeah guy looked like John Carol
Lynch his first role sleeping cop
sleeping C hey you never
[Music]
know yeah Bad to the Bone should have
just kicked in right there as SL the way
that whipped past the
camera I love how the van too is like so
steady and this police car is like
yeah oh yes ramb articus it puts the ram
in Rambo or Ben her whichever one has
the race with the
wheels I think that's Ben her I think
Ben
[Music]
Rambo yeah buddy
oh that exploit did not expect it
no
warning so many Great Cuts in this dude
oh man the editing is great I know it
was a longer movie they cut down the
editing in this has been other than that
one weird dog Guy Moment pretty
[Music]
seamless oh boy oh
boy right through the
barricade
leapt oh that's switch carves got to get
that finale rain
going chicken pie and steaks too so much
food in this town sorry I'm still on
about the I mean you're just upset at
the it was
theight I mean that's fair oh he's going
to take him out oh he gets the gun we've
seen this at so many references the gun
he's got like an artillery weapon he
just wields oh
no don't blow it up right outside of
Captain
Spaldings got to do the murder ride man
Rob Zombie was not thrilled about this
T like violence and freaks of nature
oh sh the director like we've got some
budget to blow stuff up yeah we saved it
for deep in the
movie
wow they actually just like see I was
thinking that might be like that famous
gas station said that they did shoot a
bunch of things including House of
thousand but I think it might not they
decimated it yeah unless it gets blown
up a lot and they just keep building it
back like a universal set that I'm
have
oo boy cool lights
baby yeah they are oh my
God what a chain reaction wow exploding
doin ruined your town
cop for your own safety please Evacuate
the streets
immediately receive further instruction
Christmas lights a town PA yeah the
sheriff's catac corn into the shopping
plaza like small town PA just hey goad
and call it one guys yeah it stole an
army truck blew up a gas station the
other side of town the kid is
resilient why you forget what you're
thinking and clear out what you can
still
exploding gently in the backr
sound oh it's so good teasel you and all
your men couldn't handle him before now
what makes you think you can handle him
now because God knows what damage he's
prepared to do God only knows what
damage he's prepared to do it's also
it's such a simple plot but it's so good
because of the arcs and everyone's like
investment in their roles like I buy
everyone's Arc and how we got here
there's only one man in this room that's
got half a chance that's not because I'm
better it's because he trusts me see I'm
the closest thing to family that he has
left and that may be all the edge I need
is he betraying us don't you betray
Rambo this is my town and I'm not giving
it up to you what Rambo or anybody else
you just stay the hell out of my way
what would his motivation to stop Rambo
be like an Accolade like I don't know
what Troutman yeah I think he just wants
this to be done with and he still is
like the best chance that you got of
de-escalating this [__] like yeah but
yeah like one way or another he's like
he cares but also is like I might be
able to actually help you know instead
of this idiotic rampage you guys are
perpetuating destroying your whole
town
all might be coming from inside the
house and two when these old movies have
like a radio broadcast just likeing in
the still the occasional explosion and
then like the plots moving along with
the
audio oh that gun smile and have a Coke
man just smile and have a Coke that is
an insane weapon how much would that
weigh and what's the kickback Jesus cuz
he's like lean functional strength here
that's like yeah imagine what that
weighs how much lowering of your center
of gravity is enough to counteract that
kick wa man take the road to flavor baby
I see why there's five of these this
movie is amazing when it's a fascinating
like I think the'80s especially had
these franchises where like the first
one is not the vibe you would associate
with the larger franchise yeah cuz I
didn't think this movie was be this at
all but that equalizer is like that too
equalizer feels like it it
pivots
[Music]
look at
him shot look at where he is oh y'all
runs into the gun store with that y'all
are
fudged yep oh he's trying to oh moloto
gas cans I was like why would he oh
that's why and get some decoy Ducks as
well throw them off your scent with the
decoy
[Music]
duck not generally like a big guns guy
but at the same time I'm like dude get
the variety going man go nuts stock up
get he's just going to like o fire works
yeah oh my God is he going to
shoot yep strike a
match could have used anything but he
shot it with like an anti-aircraft gun
oh my God
yeah oh boy oh
boy no it's just regular the third Act
of this movie is so different than the
first two I know they saved all the
explosions for act three but we like we
have earned this escalation but it's a
different type of it's to build tension
it feels like we've come so far since
the beginning like
yeah oh man did he leave the stairs down
yep oh dude yep oh my goodness gracious
oh he Michael Myers
us oh no wait he's just left a camera
never mind I thought rampa went outside
I was
like he's going to climb up the other it
seems like way more efficient just to
use the
ladder
no no no
no
[Music]
yeah sometimes you get shot in the when
you're karmically just true right up
main
streeto Rambo don't I don't I don't
trust you I don't trust him drop your
weapon I'm going to order the chopper
and and fly you back to brag get to the
chopper this mission is over look at him
out
there oh my God that an ocean of Cruiser
lights it's over nothing is over it
wasn't my war and I do what I had to do
to win back there I can fly a gunship I
was in charge of million dollar
equipment back here I can't even hold
the
job yeah no purpose no
more Jes oh
God where is everybody where is
everybody I had a friend was there
forth I had all these guys man back
there had always fight guyses a this kid
comes up his kid car to s Bo and the box
is wired and he open up the box [__]
blew his body all over the place
jeez I can't get
out I seven years every day
happens oh dude
wow
a get my yeah wow it's probably the
closest you've been to anybody in a very
long
time
oh damn what a monologue that was
incredible yeah what a crescendo Jesus
what a I love that the climax wasn't the
explosions yeah it wasn't like some
massive you know I don't know it was
that combo yeah like just something yeah
real personal real human it's yeah it's
the reason for all this and the opening
of the film and the end of the film are
about the person
yeah but we still get that moment yeah
you know that guy still got his come up
and a clear
[Music]
Victory oh
interesting okay that's Richard krena
all right Brian denah Brian Den's in a
ton of stuff yeah he's not to is he he's
not he's not the skipper on Gilligan
island is he we got to look him up after
because that was what a I was not
expecting that ending yeah me neither a
freeze frame look away it's okay it's
good Merry ballus reject Nation you know
what the funny thing is I already owned
this product before agreeing to do this
partnership I could have used my
influencer ring to get it for free or at
a discount but hey now you can get it at
a discount cuz this week we are of
course sponsored by manscaped as a
married man who's always on the move I
value looking sharp while keeping things
of efficient that's ranscapes
performance package 5.0 Ultra comes in
featuring the lawnmower 5.0 and it is a
game changer the package is honestly a
perfect gift for yourself or for another
man that you might know I'll give this
to John if anyone ask I pay for it out
of my own pocket but no seriously this
is easily the best because it comes with
not one but two NextGen blade heads see
the difference it's good thing I have
two now for demonstration purposes so
you got the standard trimmer for perfect
neat trim but this one the new foil
blade for that super smooth finish and
oh yeah it's all about safe GR with
their Advanced Skin safe technology plus
they're waterproof so no more crumbs on
Lo carpet the package also includes a
weed whacker 2.0 for ear and nose and I
definitely use this because look at me
I'm a hairy guy and the must have liquid
formations the crop Soo aftershave
lotion and the crop preserver ball
deodorant say goodbye to poet of
irritation and hello freshness and the
ultimate cherry on top two free gifts
manscapes premium boxers 2.0 and the
shed 2.0 toiletry bag again I already
have one the boxers I'm wearing my P
here right now and the bag is perfect
for all your grooming Essentials as you
can see so you ready to elevate your
grooming game head to manscape.com and
use code rejects for a cool 20% off plus
free shipping remember it's rejects for
20% off at manscape.com let's get those
jingle balls Hollow day ready with
manscape thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in eCommerce so whether you're
launching a passion project or scaling
to new heights Shopify is the e-commerce
Powerhouse guing you at every step from
creating your first online store to
opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and in store sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors and buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI tool that elevates
your business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on your journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth great growth exponential thank
you again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us it Powers
10% of us e-commerce backing businesses
big and small in over 175 countries
there are war-winning support always
there to guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify at only a
dollar a month at shopify.com reject all
lowercase shopify.com reject start your
Shopify success story now let's grow
together with top of five team it is an
interesting choice too cuz they let it
play initially Bruce Greenwood Guardsman
number five wow early Bruce Greenwood
early greens Guardsman five Bruce
Greenwood you know hey you got to start
somewhere man good for Buddy Joe hooker
Richard Diamond Farnsworth Bruce Barber
Benny Dobbins Will Harper and Bobby
Sergeant did the work absolutely
excellent especially in a movie like
this that was those were some incredible
stunts Michael Westmore on the makeup
that is
prolific Hollywood makeup artist man
that was incredible you know what else
is incredible Coy uh is it this shirt oh
it might be this shirt guys listen all
right I think one thing that would have
made Ram if I may you know from
experience you know I think one thing
that would have made Rambo's Journey a
little bit more palatable a little less
harsh uh you know surviving the elements
is if he had a soft and comfortable
t-shirt from reation shop he was cold
could have been close he could have
gotten a space babies of the Galaxy
t-shirt he could have got the Classic
tickets he could have got America's ass
for crying out he might have not been
pulled over in the first place
preventing this entire thing from
happening you know all of this
destruction damage and Carnage could
have been prevented with a t-shirt to
reation shop.com so hey guys if you want
us in all seriousness if you want to
support the channel it's one of our
favorite ways to do so we got a ton of
designs more popping up uh frequently
not not like every single month but but
pretty frequently there's something new
and interesting to look at so uh hey if
you want to support the nation Rock a
little swag show your pride uh we very
much appreciate you doing so but uh but
yes fraking a First Blood Part One Good
Golly Miss Molly yeah uh that was so
much better than I expected that was a
different tone a different feel a
different movie I've seen the art a lot
I've seen especially this Rambo First
Blood Part Two art a lot so I expected
that movie and I'm curious if that movie
is the movie I think it is cu I haven't
seen it either and if of you want us to
watch it leave a comment below hit a
like but I do find uh a lot of the 80s
stuff is more my jam like when you do
you know what letter box is the the
website the social media app yeah yeah
where you where you review movies and
list movies and interact with ciles
exactly it is a a snoody little hoyy
toyy but very approachable they have a
specific knife design I like that by
Jimmy ly of the Arkansas knife Smiths
well thank you Jimmy ly fil filmed in
Panavision Beautiful film filmed in
Canada you knew it you knew it you knew
it but Portland is South uh that said uh
what was I saying uh tone 80s oh uh so
when I look at my letter box um the 80s
is my favorite decade you can actually
look at like what you rate what decades
were strong what comedy drama like you
can it gives you tons of stats it's dope
and I've rated 2600 or so movies uh and
yeah so I went through like all of the
movies that I had on AMC and actually
rated when I saw them and I went through
and like all the movies I literally went
through the top hundred movies of each
year rated everything that I remembered
and the 80s are always my top like the '
80s is my jam and I found that the 80s
movies I missed this Demolition Man
Judge Dread are my biggest surprises
because I either missed them because of
like it not being what my family watched
growing up or I had the wrong impression
of it and I didn't want to have that
actor ruin for me so it's been really
cool especially with this uh going back
and and watching stuff from that era
that's actually better than I would have
expected and still feeling like it it
actually makes me think the 80s is
better than I already thought it was do
you know what I mean like I'm also
watching The Greatest Hits yeah yeah
yeah like Rambo's obviously got five of
them there are a lot of the earmarks of
the 80s that yeah there are some that
that dip into wackiness and campiness
and and and you know the 80s cheese and
coked out qualities that that you might
think of but I think the stumble upon
like a Walmart 80s movie most likely so
I'll be just seeing I think yeah we're
saying yeah the cream is particular good
for a decade that I think gets most of
its flowers for like the Nostalgia
Classics like oh eat tea or things like
that you know uh and you know amblin
things that that we're often hearkening
back to uh and you know the 80s I think
it's easy to forget you know do have a
certain edge of like real Cinema that 41
years ago this movie came out yeah and
and real Cinema that like is congealing
with a more marketable genre like an
action movie or something like that you
know and uh and yeah like it makes me
fascin to go back in in in a film School
kind of way like revisit the decade
because too one thing that fascinates me
is is this is a 1982 or released in 1982
so you know if you're thinking about
decades and tonality you know you're
sort of in that transition point where
the style of the 70s is slowly giving
way to the sensibility of the 80s and
and morphing into what the 80s you know
kind of defining aesthetic might be you
know when you get to like the middle of
the decade so here it's like you do have
certain earmarks that feel like yes this
is an ' 80s movie but it's being so
early on in the decade I feel like you
still have a lot of That 70s sensibility
where like again there is passage of
time there is a little bit of that like
cinematic uh you know use of time but I
feel like for the most part everything
is like really immediate and it all
grows out of that immediate seed of like
he's walking into town uh he sees his
old friend's uh you know Mom or whoever
that was he goes and sees the relative
of of you know his uh you know ex-
brother in arms the last we find out
later which is also I like that we
waited to find that out yeah totally and
then you know and then he wanders into
town the guy tries to take him out of
town and then slowly everything just
kind of builds from there and and it
grows into this thing where once you're
at the end and you're back in town and
everything's on fire like it does feel
like this isn't even that long of a
movie this is an hour and a half it does
so much more with an hour and a half
than I would have thought possible I
feel like I watched a 2hour like you
know over two yeah not a bad way in that
way of like it's not dragging it just
feels very substantial and it and except
for maybe one cut here or there it feels
like well finessed and well edited and
paste and all that stuff it it really I
love that everyone's Arc made sense to
them and we immediately knew the
archetypes like we we get to grow more
finding out like you know he's he's a
bit that adds layers to it but very
quickly we know what he stands for we
very quickly know you know those cops we
very quickly like I liked that I didn't
quite trust the general or the the
but yeah but I also like that you know
where he was coming from still made
sense even if he betrayed Rambo I still
would have been like I get where he came
from but I I didn't like that I was
judging him because I wanted to like him
so I liked that inevitably he did help
you know as a ranking officer are you
going to pull some kind of yeah some
something where where you're trusting on
our
shared what's right for the country cuz
I could see it going that way and I and
I I also think it's really bold in in I
consider the 80s a very pro cop era and
this wasn't and I like that because I do
think there is you give anyone power
they can abuse it you give anyone with
an ego a gun they can abuse it you can
give anyone that's emotionally charged
uh about something that they don't quite
understand they can abuse it and and it
didn't paint them as mustache twirling
it definitely made them look at times
ignorant it definitely made them like
you know shoot first ask questions later
but that's real life with a lot of
people so I like that it was not pro cop
but it also wasn't like this is just
black and white villainy because it
allowed the movie to feel way more
interesting by the decisions that got
made and I think it also allowed the
movie to feel like there was weight and
Nuance in decisions Beyond even what we
saw on screen like I want to know more
about a lot of things because it wasn't
so transparent yeah it's like I want to
go back and look at some of the stuff
with that main Sheriff character because
I like he talks about you know also it
it seems like he's an ex Soldier to some
degree as well or has some of that
experience cuz he talked about it like I
couldn't again I want to go back and
clarify whether he's just talking about
like you know the the war time as they
say later was difficult on everyone but
he's got like medals and stuff in his
office and so part of me was thinking
like it almost seems like you have two
sides of a coin whereas like this guy
has kind of been lucky enough to come
back and do the dream in a way he lives
in this like peaceful little mountain
town and is like completely removed from
the realities of the conflict and and
you know especially the view on soldiers
at this point in time coming back from
the Vietnam War and stuff you know uh uh
it's almost like it's so extreme in his
effort to like get this guy out of here
don't want any of this in our peaceful
happy little town and then you on the
flip side you've got Rambo who's like I
can't not be living in this ever right
this all I have for seven years and and
when did Vietnam War end oh goodness I
see those are those are historical
elements I better audience
during the I thought I thought it was
mid-70s so when he said 7 years ago I
was wondering if this was like real time
sure cuz like that would have been 75 or
when they filmed this that would have
been 74 because they probably filmed it
in 81 but I I do like that this felt
like it was of its time like it felt
like it was in early 80s both in the
film making but also the characters
because of those ramifications and and I
do like that we had questions like I I
like that we want to know more I am
curious though if because this was so
good like you talked about with 80s
movies like is it diminishing returns
because it's even Rambo is not called
Rambo it's called First Blood the second
one's called Rambo First Blood Part Two
making it like the guy you like and by
the third one it's like Rambo three like
does it get less nuanced like is it
something that's like we're just going
to shoot stuff in the third one it looks
like it from these posters that sh yeah
I mean that's the thing is is I feel
like I can imagine how this would easily
and quickly shift into something that
that I would imagine maybe some level of
aspiration toward relevant commentary in
the following sequels to one degree or
another however I can see that being
very I don't expect them to have this
sensibility where I think it would just
be like too dreary to franchise for
people if you were always dealing with
like the real weight of trauma of these
you know forgotten guys coming home and
struggling to find a place in the world
like I feel like some of that will be
there but I feel like it'll probably
prioritize like him being a resourceful
badass and it'll probably give you I
would imagine more explosions and
probably like more overtly it's like
this rides a good line in terms of like
the police that that you know are sort
of embroiled in the main part of this
conflict even before you have like the
National Guard and stuff coming in like
all those characters are riding a line
where it's like they're not likable
we're not really in their Corner ever
they're not really that sympathetic even
but there's something about them that
that like you said isn't just like
absolutely cartoon whereas I expect in
the future installments we will have
just like these are really bad guys and
we got to see them die will we fight
Russians it's the you know I mean like
it it'll get no disrespect to Russians
but like it gets into that time it makes
me curious and yeah I I imagine that
it'll become more lky and hamfisted with
those elements and maybe a bit more
negligent with those elements I don't
think he has scars in the third one look
at look at like it looks like he's just
oiled up and and that's the thing too is
I bet it'll get shinier and it'll get
more sort of Hollywood like this is an
interesting time in cinema to me because
it's like you have movies like this that
have a lot of Pulp and exploitable
elements and things that make a
blockbuster make an action movie or
whatever the genre is but it's also like
never really taking a break from the
like stakes and the emotional PA that's
cast over everything like it's it's
weird I think they did use to make these
movies that have potential to be
Blockbusters or to appeal in ways that
action movies in this case do but that
are like always sort of being a film too
and I can see this turning into a thing
where it's like no let's let's make this
a movie now and and yeah so like I I
really like just yeah having all that to
chew on and the fact that yeah there's
so much about you know the the weird
tension between everybody and you know
these this yeah these guys who are
forgotten and struggling and who you
know everyone just wants to pass off and
I like that even though Troutman again
is a comforting presence and the closest
presence he is yeah sort of removed and
nobody really knows what the experience
of this guy is and it is heartbreaking
because when he's monologuing at the end
it's like yeah man that was a rough
monologue I me beautiful yeah and as
many legitimate reasons as there are to
take issue with various Wars and prot
and and and you know protest those
actions at the same time there is a
point that like you also just have no
idea unless you've been there what it's
like to be in those positions and so it
just makes you take pause I think and go
like yeah how how do the rest of us you
know the people for whom you are
fighting you know for whom you're trying
to give the privilege of a life without
this level of extreme want and violence
horror yeah you know at the same time
how can there be a balance of
appreciation you know when yeah like
your politicians and the people making
the decisions about this stuff are not
helping at all a lot of people get
thrown under the bus yeah and everyone's
trying to maintain this peaceful home
state at the cost of like there's a
poison in the well it's at the cost of
you know like truly looking out for each
other and truly embodying the thing we
were fighting for the most and all this
like mirrored imagery I just love the
way you know you start out again idilic
beautiful sunlit you know Pond and and
Farmhouse and then the second he gets
that bad news the weather all gets
dreier yeah he's walking in the shade I
love you notic I hadn't caught up on
that and the and the movie ends in in a
fiery suburb like it starts green and it
ends Bleak yeah and then you go to the
town and it's like oh but this is still
like nice and cozy and it and it's
increasingly more and more like a war
zone and there's just like encampments
and the National Guards you there's
trucks and that war can happen anywhere
like it brought War home and it made it
feel like that town was like you know a
war torn little town that was so idilic
yeah and in some ways I mean again I am
not an expert on like I want to I want
to do at this stage of my life like a
true Deep dive back into history and and
learn relearn some things but it did
seem like in a way almost this situation
sort of mirrors this doomed Endeavor
that from my understanding sort of was
the Vietnam War in that you know we went
in someplace and instead of leaving
after a certain point when it seems
maybe reasonable to do so no it's just
like we got to just keep on escalating
this we can't back down you know and
that's very much what the cops are doing
here they're just like we can't just let
this go you know we got to we got to
show our display our power and and
convince ourselves especially in the
context here that we have control and
all that like I don't know yeah this is
so much more Rich than expected I want
more more audience if you'd like to
watch Rambo First Blood Part Two please
leave a comment below please if you're
still watching this leave a like on your
way out please leave a comment on the
way out telling us which of the rambos
is your favorite without spoilers and if
you want us to watch anything else in
this vein I've been enjoying this 80s
kick so please let us know what else
you'd like us to get into and hit that
subscription Bell so we know that you
want us to and you can get notified
about us watching those very things that
is going to do it for this episode of
John and Coy watch cool stuff we got a
patron want to shout out you want to
shout out Ricardo Martinez I would love
to shout out Ricardo our man Ricardo
Martinez Ricardo Martinez not only is
your name beautifully salic as it goes
through not only does it include a z
which is not a common thing I got a y in
my name I like a sprinkled in there but
Ricardo Martinez sounds like you could
give Ricky Martin a run for his money
and I feel like there's just like Ricky
Martin Ricardo Martinez it feels like a
an escalation like he's the Charmeleon
to Ricky Martin's Charmander you know
what I mean like he's the evolution
Ricky Martin Short for Ricardo Martinez
hip shaking even more roses clch even
Char rard I don't know Ricardo but I
might give him Charizard holographic
Charizard yeah like he's got that that
uniqueness because you know Ricky
Martin's short for Ricardo Martinez
because he's a into his fully fledged
self we appreciate your humbleness your
graciousness your generosity and your
dope ass name dope ass name thank you so
much for being here buddy we're grateful
for you be well people we'll see you
[Music]
soon